what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and ever since he who remains was
ruthlessly murdered by a bisexually
atomic blonde with a grudge we nerd
babies of the kang gang
speculation nation have been screaming
at our nearby bathroom mirrors for the
candy man
to appear in the mcu once more because
god damn
can jonathan major's act that man was
standing on top of the desk
because we all got kang fever and the
only prescription
is more kang bell and with the eternals
being the next major cosmic mcu title
coming up in theaters you already know
that we here at new rockstars heavily
suspect
a kangmeo or two to potentially pop up
in this film about earth's first
superheroes guiding human evolution but
how exactly could we see loki season 1
factors like kang or even the tva
implemented into the plot of chloe
zhao's latest multi-millennia banger of
an eternals film well let's talk about
it my nerd babies now the most
obvious way that we could see loki
elements popping up in eternals is
through the kang variant of rama tut now
if you are a true
loyal rock star then you have already
gotten the lowdown of how kang went back
in time to play pharaoh in ancient
egyptian times as the king
rama tut for my video of all the
versions of kang explained if you
haven't seen it go watch it right now
well
after you watch this video and like i
said in that video we are extremely
likely to see a rama tut variant pop up
in the mcu because rama tut is one of
the most
iconic versions of kang as it is the
very first one introduced you know
before the fantastic four sent his
tanned ass
mcflying back to the future but since
the fantastic four have yet to be
officially introduced in the mcu i can
totally see
marvel studios secretly inserting a
jonathan major's ramatun appearance in
eternals by having the eternals confront
this kang variant
directly because as we've seen in the
eternals trailer there are hints that
the eternals have had dealings in
ancient egypt in the past particularly
in this shot of makari's speed reading
as you can see from the shot
egyptian statues of a black figure
holding an egyptian ankh
and a black cat being a black cat
pointed this quite clearly because
everybody knows that egyptians were
crazy about their anks
just as much as cats are crazy about
ankles
like the mother can't get enough of that
so because the eternals were
charged by the celestials to use their
celestial given powers and technology
to protect humanity from the shadows and
help them progress and evolve slowly
over time i feel like a time traveling
tourist
ruling over egypt with an iron ipad
might be something they might need to
address
either through a simple you know
diplomatic conversation or
my personal favorite senseless sci-fi
violence
let's do the violence let's let's do the
sci-fi violence because that's just more
fun
and i'm sure that the giant celestial
ship that the eternals be whipping
around
has the ability to sense strange energy
signatures coming from ramatut's
futuristic tools weapons and time travel
technology on an otherwise
techless planet from the ancient past
and speaking of ramatut's time traveling
technology we may have already seen some
of that
teased in episode 5 of loki with that
oddly placed
sphinx in the void now there are things
that we all need to live a happy life
like a steady stream of marvel content a
high resolution monitor to zoom and
enhance background details of all the
marvel stuff that we watch
and a comfortable mattress designed just
for you helix sleep makes premium
mattresses and bedding that are
customized to fit your needs and
conveniently shipped right to your door
helix made a sleep quiz that matches
your unique body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
for you i took the quiz and got matched
with the dusk lux
helix mattress because i wanted a medium
firm mattress with lumbar support that
sleeps real cool
cooler than you and that's impossible
i've had my helix mattress for a couple
of weeks now and i freaking
love it like it totally delivers on all
the great features and if you sleep with
a partner
both of you can take the quiz and find
the mattress that meets both of your
needs i don't have a partner so i don't
have that that's a problem
i'm so alone and the best part about all
of this that helix delivers your
mattress
right to your door for free they will
not charge you extra and it comes rolled
up in a box and it's super easy to set
it up all by yourself it's like a cool
magic trick that they can fit an entire
mattress into a box
that size like it's very weird it's kind
of like a clown car but for a mattress
so helix has a 100 night sleep trial so
you get more than three months to make
sure that you love
your helix mattress and if you don't
they'll pick it up for you and you'll
get a full refund
no questions asked i love my helix and i
think you will love your helix as well
so if you're looking for a new bed
check out helix and you can click the
link below or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars and get up to two hundred
dollars off your helix mattress this is
no
ordinary sphinx manure babies because as
we discussed in past videos
this is a sphynx with a nose kang has
used a nosey sphinx as a time machine
in the comics so since he who remains
already told us that he weaponized
the gassy eliath to end the multiversal
kangdemonium
this sphinx could have easily been a
time machine that was used by a rama tut
variant that lost world war king
or was just straight up pruned by hero
remains tva
thus potentially pointing to kang's past
dealings in ancient egypt or
at least an affinity towards that time
period but on the topic of king's
technology in relation to celestial
technology i think there could also be a
link towards that celestial technology
and
that master tempet that hero remains
wore on his hand to me they look very
visually similar with some type of
mystical golden power
flowing through both of them he remains
his master temped having golden cracks
and the
ship that the eternals used being
surrounded or covered in these golden
rings and both sets of technology
seem to be telepathically connected to
the user that is using him with both he
who remains and the eternal fastos
using them to make gold-lined
presentations of sorts and of course
sylvie summoning a time door
mid-kiss even though she's never used
that piece of technology
in her life have you ever tried to
summon a time door mid-kiss
i can't even open a door mid-kiss i
would kill us both
so there's a possibility that kang's
master watch could actually be based on
some type of primordial celestial
technology technology
that we could see a king variant like
rama tut or some other kang
stealing from the eternals or even
directly from the celestials themselves
in those earlier days of humanity you
know in an attempt to be styling like he
who remains
or maybe just maybe tang secretly makes
a deal with one of the more
curious eternals like makari who appears
to be just as obsessed with collecting
historical mementos as he will remain
seems to be or
maybe we see fastos fall in love with a
kang myriad who uses
fastest's affinity for celestial
technology to his advantage because you
know kang's kind of an so maybe
we see a post-credits scene in eternals
with one of these scenarios who knows
kevin knows but kevin won't respond to
my emails he never does
but though rama tut is the most likely
gang variant for this egyptian time
period
a kang cameo isn't just limited to
ancient egypt in the loki assembled
episode jonathan majors even said that
each item from he who remained his
entire outfit was plucked from different
eras of earth's history so a kang could
literally appear
anywhere in any time which makes me
wonder what do you guys think like do
you think we'll see kang and eternals
and if so
what era or time period would you like
to see him the most but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
and please
be sure to follow me at mastertainment
if you want to see me tweet some weird
please follow new rockstars
wherever we are and most importantly
on youtube where you can hit that
notification bellows and get
notifications whenever we upload a video
because we'd be uploading every day and
we don't want you to miss
anything but also please go to
newrockstarsmerch.com we have a really
cool loki inspired shirt with mobius on
a jet ski
please head there so you can be styling
all your friends anyways thank you guys
for watching i'll see you guys later
goodbye
[Music]
you